welcome to this video as I said rematch
yeah I had a game in between against
another player but to be honest this was
a very fishy game I had some I had very
quickly some doubts about them about
this player and I stopped the recording
so this loss is not documented on video
yeah it was a bit of a strange game it
was a new account and all the signs of
weird things going on so yeah I didn't
really feel like recording this let's
see is she repeating the e takes d4 line
she is so let's see what's going on now
she's getting going for 96 or for c6
this is the all-rookie 8 f 3 c 6 this is
that the other modern way to play no
she's again doing this so i really liked
my position so i'm curious where she's
going to improve i would just repeat i
think f5 is also mushi play tonight f4
in the game before that
yeah this is sometimes a problem yeah
you play two games against the same
opponent and you lost the first one and
you think okay where am I try to improve
now trying to think of new lines other
ideas whatever and yeah you don't really
remember what to do or you don't have a
clear idea we had to improve and this
disgusting time quite often and finally
you're going to play the Musa that you
have played in the early game anyway and
now she has played the same stuff as in
the game before but has spent time on it
yeah this black have many alternatives I
really don't know I mean you can always
trade stuff and I like on d4 and and
just check okay we had then f5 this is
what she played last time cheeks now I
took on a high right to kind of fire the
absolute and now she's doing that but
this is this is giving black this
somewhat weak pawn on f5 or not let me
think about it I mean I can take c6 play
play Bishop g4 for the same position as
I had earlier come let's do that this is
a very pragmatic thing it was good for
white so why not repeat it maybe knight
at 5-4 stronger but there were some
technical issues with that check really
I can take and Queen a five check that
is some that's not really an improvement
okay um queen is probably coming to e7
yeah the the e-file I'm going for Quincy
three now and now I'm not going for 23
let's see here fp1 rupee one immediately
now KROQ one black can take and play be
three
yes still-still just the quincy 30 it's
still the right decision if i go rook e1
now rook takes you one is not going to
work they're going I'm going to trade
one pair of brooks yeah okay well this
is a chatot convenient and Gamble king
after and I have a pretty clear idea
what to do look d1 d3 a 3 they don't
even need to set my pawns in motion
quickly flag as a hard time to keep
their pond yeah and this is also nice
getting to be 5 or p7
let's also this more be 384 tt-take h7
simply
and next I'm going to push the pawns
check okay check
now that's okay for Luke edge form or is
it I it's okay that's really okay so
this is all protected g45 or King King
f4 it's not really doing much Jeff
what's this what's this maybe a little
bit M precise mmm I can play
and it wasn't that wasn't exactly great
technical play yeah okay I mean it it
will win but it wasn't it was great I
can march up to f5 and then push the G
porn it's a very weird way to play but
it does win check points are just
quicker but I certainly had two easier
ways to do it check check
check
always have to look at steam mates and
stuff but black as night falls I yeah
she seems she has a problem with this
line somehow i turn it needs to good
position somehow for white I really
don't know the theoretical evaluation
actually I doubt that f5 is good at all
but i really don't know it yeah okay
here here is an interesting moment I
took here just because well I knew that
from the earlier game that this was good
where we had a different move order I
wasn't here you know what I wasn't sure
what exactly I'm actually I was thinking
that this might be an idea for black but
this is a good move right and this this
kind of tactic is always in the mix but
I have root d4 so it's not working and
this means that probably I'm good here
because I get to be 5 and this is even
better than the game this is the same
tradition ahead before with a
comfortable position but here I suspect
he expected this move I would have
played c5 and this is better for white
what can you do this f5 is I don't know
if this is a good line it doesn't look
like it I mean yeah I'm just picking up
the pond for for nowhere for no
compensation ready oh I could have taken
a 5 that was that was an easy solution
that didn't think of it this is actually
also good it's it's keeping a very big
advantage this rook endgame is just to
win because the it's a pawn okay but
it's free porn islands with two isolated
pawns against two islands that are
completely safe and blackheads has no
way to save that played a bit strange
from a technical project you actually
some somewhere around here I don't think
that this was this was a bit strange but
probably probably wins chatham it it is
winning ultimately maybe it was so bad
it looked strange to me
but it seems to win the other the the
real issue here is the opening I know
that this is a normal line let's say it
is a bit out of fashion because it is
believed to be slightly better for white
but what we got wasn't slightly better
but much better from white track maybe
maybe something other than f5 I don't
know what but I mean black can always
play a passive move like a five or
passive I mean yeah an on concrete move
like Bishop d7 a five or something like
that but well I always believe in in the
in the center here and with the knight
on c6 it's it's very difficult to break
against that okay thanks for watching